so according to Russell 3000 index which
tracks performance of the top 3,000
largest US stocks they did a study to
find out companies that lost their CEO
in the last two years what percentage
were fired
what percentage they resigned they
realize 52% were fired
48% resigned so why 52% were fired so
some of you guys started asking the
questions Pat what do you think about
what happened would Adam Newman from we
work and all these seals getting fired
recently what's the cause of that why is
that taking place we want to do some
research and a couple numbers I got here
for you one of them is a study on C 73
CEOs who were fired
they shared elite leading reasons for
their dismissal and another one here is
study from Forbes and study on 1087
board members on why they decided to
fire a CEO so in today's episode I'll
cover that and I'll give you reasons why
CEOs get fired and what to do to make
sure you don't get fired so let's get
right into it the first thing I want to
look at is the following there's a study
done by LinkedIn they looked at 12,000
CEOs who have 50 plus employees from 20
different countries to see what they did
before they became CEOs and this is what
they gathered number one most common
first jobs of these CEOs is they were
first consultants then the other one is
software engineer then analysts sales
manager project manager account manager
manager founder associate software
developer these are top ten then the
second one was most common first job
functions what they were doing with that
function their first job before they
became CEOs number one was business
going around shaking hands getting to
know people very interesting and
insightful to know that people who are
good with people eventually become seals
number two was sales think about it
number one is bizdev number two is sales
then it's engineering technical then
info text and consulting finance
entrepreneurship operations marketing
that's what they had now the next part
is looking at right before they become
CEOs what did they do before and what
percentage of them were directors
directors of a department directors of
this before they became CEOs 72% before
becoming a CEO they were a director 72
percent of them when director then the
Cassio's with the company and outside of
that this is very interesting it's how
many the CEOs were recruited externally
from another company how many the CEOs
were promoted internally very very
interesting here 20% were promoted
internally 80% came from the outside you
know some people would have thought
maybe more him from inside than external
but 80% came from outside meaning they
hired a headhunter
they hired a corn fairy a recruiting
company we're looking for CEO somebody
went out there and found him they spend
their $200,000 on the seal and then that
person came in on only 20% was promoted
internally this is your something to
look at on how folks end up becoming
seals having said that now let's look at
why CEOs get fired the first one I want
to look at as a CNS see a study that I
saw from CNN where the actual seals that
were fired
I think it's 80 73 of them that were
fired what was the leading reason for
number one reason was poor business
performance that was 30% of it number
two was relationship issues with the
board 26% number three was a lack of key
skill set which is 22% and last but not
least was alienating the management team
which is 12 person that's tough to do
but it's very common because some people
don't want to talk to their management
team because the management team is
typically the one that's most critical
of the CEO they're working and so
they'll kind of create a certain
distance between them and then there is
no relationship and then sometime it's
too late and you no longer have
influence we'll get deeper into that now
here's the next one
this is from Forbes and this is very
insightful because it's the actual board
members a thousand 87 of them who decide
I think we gotta fire the CEO how they
came to their decision and why they said
I don't think this person was qualified
to be a CEO anymore very interesting
look what they said five reasons number
one reason 31% would they would they
mismanaged change so we're going through
a different season we're going through
change they mismanaged change they
didn't know how to
they either hurt the culture on how was
with the company and then it was a new
thing or going into a new thing they
didn't know what new idea is to come up
with but the whole thing is they
mismanaged second one ignoring customers
was 28% number
three was tolerating low performance
interesting that 27% just visualized the
board you got seven people sitting there
five people sitting there nine people
sitting there saying this CEO I like
them I like her they seem like a nice
guy they seem like a nice you know this
is somebody that we feel good about but
why are they tolerating low performance
why are they not pushing their team the
investors the board is saying you know
we gotta have some other that's gonna
come in here really be able to drive
there was number three reason number
four denying reality yeah I don't really
think that's what we're going through
they're denied listen if we go like this
we could potentially go out of business
the next two years yeah I don't really
think it's as bad as people think it is
denying reality is 23% and last one is
too much talk not enough action you look
at this this isn't just somebody singing
without experience it's 73 CEOs that
were fired and it's a thousand 87 board
of board members that gave feedback on
why they decided to vote on firing a CEO
makes you think so it prompted me to
make a list here on why CEOs get fired
number one it's obvious you lose the
board once you lose the board and the
board doesn't feel good about you you
know what happens your number two is in
the middle of a scandal let's talk about
this because this is what many of you
send me messages on both on YouTube and
on Instagram to say Pat can you talk
about some of this stuff let me give you
some of the scandals that you've been
hearing about number one is Papa John's
racial slur he said that boom he had to
step down
number two Travis kalanick sexism and
frat culture that video came out with
him talking to one of his drivers and
the driver was recording it it got a
several million views and then in uber
they were talking about it it was too
much partying and the true culture
wasn't that fair for men and women all
this stuff boom he had to step down
number three Tony Hayward which is a
very interesting story because Tony
Hayward was the CEO of British Petroleum
I want to say in 2010 and they had this
massive spill they had this massive
issue that took place explosion it was
very problematic spill oh all this stuff
that happened and they lost eleven
employees eleven employees died okay so
now he's going through this whole thing
there is this very epic scene
interview that they do that you got a
watch it's like six seconds you got to
watch it we're asking them questions
after he lost 11 employees the families
of the 11 employees are contacting this
guy and here's what Tony Hayward says in
an interview he says look nobody wants
to do this thing to be done than me
nobody wants it to be done more than me
I want my life back
it's the line of what he said you just
lost 11 employees who lost their life
they're never gonna get a life he says
on an interview I want my life back
three months later he resigned it was
done because and it was coming it's not
mismanagement of money or things like
that
it's more the humane aspect of you
dealing with your people what do you
mean you want your life back 11 people
the way you handled crisis
wasn't good gone and then Carlos horn
who's the chairman of Nissan Renault and
I believe Mitsubishi he had a scandal
that took place with him with Mitsubishi
company assets and misleading investors
in November a 2018 I think he got
arrested in Japan when his issue was
taking place and this was a this was a
person that was CEO and chairman a
chairman of three different companies
not small companies Renault Nissan
Mitsubishi and all of a sudden all this
stuff came about there's a video you can
watch about his wife and the kind of
study what happened here but he had to
step down and last but not least the
recent one would Adam Newman hey really
we work is what 48 billion dollars and
then after a little bit of research
they're doing well you do sign 15-year
leases and you do get it at a discount
and you kind of selling get a little bit
up so but what if those 15 year leases
some people cut their contracts with you
because the economy's bad I don't really
know if you're worth 48 billion I think
you really only worth fifteen billion
dollars his net worth dropped from four
point two four two point one and then he
was using companies resources for his
own personal lifestyle and at the same
time you know doing a little bit of
drugs while at work so let's just say
those are true I don't know remember I'm
reading these articles or what the media
is telling us and what we're reading
about but if a decision was made to fire
somebody
we better believe some of the stuff is
true right this scandal a mistake hurts
anybody everybody's in that place that's
me that's any of you that are CEOs you
have to know that the number one of the
reasons why SEOs get fired is in the
middle of a scandal it can happen to
anybody so you kind of kind of control
some of your decisions that you're
making
next on top of this tree was not meeting
expectations very simple number four not
not the majority control is a technical
one if you control most of the board and
the board wants to fire you you can't
fire you I have a guy that we were
talking about possibly up working with
the sky and he was kind of asking me for
counsel and he said he wants to bring
you an investor in but he doesn't want
to lose control because what if the
board decides to fire him well if he
doesn't bring the investor in he needs
the resources to get bigger so he
doesn't want to take the money because
he loses too many board seats well
they'll get three he'll have to and the
three can vote against him to fire him
he doesn't want that kind of risk he's
worried about it so he doesn't want to
get the money so to him it's more
important control so again that's very
basic and technical new buyer somebody
comes in you were the old CEO we're
about 100 percent of it guess what
yeah you know what we want to bring your
own CEO I mean we like you it's cool but
do you mind sitting here as a consultant
and maybe when we need you we'll pay you
$1,000 an hour 500 bucks an hour
whatever it is and we'll give you a
return now $50,000 right now that it's
needed but we want to bring your CEO and
so you're far thank you you can publicly
resign because it's better if you resign
rather than us firing you but I think
that's the direction we want to go no
problem
indirect way of getting fired it's a new
bar coming it happens all the time
sometimes the CEO fires themselves I
just don't think I'm the guy for this
job and I'm not a number one guy thought
I was but I'm not I'm better being a
number two guy and I'll step down I'll
go back to my position no problem you
fire yourself and you step away then the
next one is a lost influence over the
team very basic we talked about this a
little bit this happens all the time
when one loses influence way either
they're golfing too much they're away
too much they're not in and out of the
office regularly they're kind of big
shouting it a little bit and the people
are like wait a minute
you come here you're demanding people to
get to work and then you're going to
your golf you know game that you have
and no you don't really you're not
really working that hard I don't know if
the board really knows about it we're
doing all the work you only here ten
hours a week what the hell is going on
over here
you lose your team that eventually leaks
and Board finds out about it and then
company has outgrown the ce o--'s
ability sometimes a company you may have
been a CEO of a company doing 50 million
years you don't good maybe you were CEO
of a company now doing 100 million
he's still doing okay but the company
gets to do in a billion dollars here
you're no longer somebody that should be
the CEO the company had a billion
dollars your company outgrows the CEO we
need a different kind of a CEO to manage
a billion-dollar company and a ten
billion dollar company etc etc sometimes
people stay
sometimes people outgrown their bring
the CEO from the outside and that's some
of the reasons why seals get fired now
how to prevent how to prevent number one
know that you can get fired
every time I have a meeting with my
staff I say guys do you know who gets
fired here the most they said who I said
I guarantee you none of you guys get
fired more than the CEO does I get fired
every day what do you mean every time a
client cancels I get fired
it's their way of saying I'd rather do
business with somebody else than you
every time an agent leaves every time an
employee leaves every time any negative
happens it's a form of getting fired and
by the way if I don't do a good job you
fire me I can't fire you of course you
can fire me how do I fire you I simply
say I want to go work somewhere else
it's a form of you firing me to go work
for another CEO another company that's a
form of getting fired you never thought
about it that way so if you're a CEO
running a company keep that in mind it
doesn't matter that you're CEO all the
pressures on you you share the position
with different department but it's very
important to know that you can get fired
don't get arrogant to the point that I'm
so important I'm so needed they will
never fire me yes you number one need to
know you can get fired number two growth
in sales is not looking good if sales is
not up everything else is irrelevant
sales a lot of times forgives you look
at today's election time what is the one
reason why a lot of people are not
paying attention to anything else when
it comes up to Trump's reelection
economy is doing good look at the
economy as sales when sales is good
people can sometimes overlook some of
the other areas because sales is good so
you got to grow your sales three is you
don't pour into your team anymore so you
got to start pouring into your team you
got to start kind of believing in them
and encouraging them and have a plan for
them long term talking about business
planning with them developing new
leaders when you're developing new
leaders people say well when this guy's
in my life
I become a better human being wow this
is good I like working with them because
I'm becoming a better leader well then
you're needed because you are a leader
that's developing leaders next one
bringing in new customers sometimes when
a seal goes through company and a
company does very good and he brings
three customers that have a relationship
with them from a prior company that's
like clout hey this is good we need this
guy because those three big customers
that are with us now is because of the
CEO while we like this guy he's got some
context let's keep him six bring new
partners in you come into the company or
CEO hey I think we gotta bring this
technology person hey we got to bring
this PR company here and we got to bring
this product over here we got to bring
this thing over here all these partners
that are being brought up they're being
brought here because of you the new CEO
so you're now deep relationship within
the company of all these people that are
there doing business with the company
because of your not just customers but
partners and technology now next you
create new alliances you're now good
with the CMO you're not good with the
CFO you're now good with the CEO you're
not good with the president you're not
good with the you know director of this
VP of this you now have alliances people
are like in your voice they're like in
your philosophy of leading your winning
votes and last but not least there's
mismatch in culture let me talk about
mismatch in culture so sometimes the CEO
comes to culture and the culture clashes
for example say we got five different
types of CEOs somebody's extremely
driven we're gonna go out there and do
this hey we're competitive we're gonna
beat number than one and we're gonna be
number one one day and we're gonna do
this very very very very competitive
right you know or somebody that's very
you know this is very idealistic it's
about learning it's about improving it's
about getting better we're gonna be okay
we're gonna get better we're gonna read
this thing we're gonna study this thing
that's idealistic so three stewards safe
you're loyal you're dependable your help
for your reliable right it's a very good
guy to have Jesus Stewart to the company
different kind of a CEO I'm here to help
you guys out I'm here to work together
I'm here to do this diplomat diplomat is
somebody that does what with everybody
you know he's good with customers
diplomat is good with compliance
diplomat knows how to talk to sales
diplomat knows how to talk to board
diplomat knows how to talk to media
diplomat knows how to talk to a lot of
different people maybe not the best
driver but it's good at bringing people
together as synergizing so it's a good
culture and last but not least it's the
technical guy or the gal knows a lot
about the products knows a lot about the
industry knows a lot about everything I
just had a conference called this
morning I was getting an update on some
of these insurance companies you know
the changing of CEO
one of these companies that's a 200
billion dollar company they were giving
me some insight on what's going on with
this company they went from a CEO that
was extremely technical when he's the
CEO the company started going down he
knew more about products than anybody
else but he's all technical and he was
always afraid because he knew so much so
because he knew so much he never moved
then they went and brought somebody else
that was more of a driver and he's a
younger guy because they want to grow
the company see this guy was safe but it
mismatched the culture because the
company wanted to grow not to bring in
some audio so if the board is trying to
hire and replace and get a new CEO if
the CEO doesn't match the culture it's
not gonna work if he's way too
competitive that culture is not
competitive it's not gonna work if he's
very relaxed chill technical and the
culture is very competitive it's not
there's got to be something that there's
a mismatch what the culture word works
taupe continues to grow the company so
these are some of the things when it
comes down to you thinking about why
CEOs get fired and why some CEOs are
able to stick around by the way every
one of the numbers I shared with you
were gonna put the links below on top of
that I got two other videos I want you
to watch number one video it's an
interview that's probably the most Mario
would you agree underrated video we've
had interview i sat down with chip
Wilson chip Wilson is not a social media
figure many of you guys don't know who
he is he's worth four billion dollars he
started Lululemon and he grew it into a
twelve billion dollar machine and he had
to go through the experience of
replacing himself CEO board it's very
technical so if this kind of stuff
intrigues you he's gonna give you so
much insight himself so go watch the
chip was an interview and then another
one it was a video I made a year ago a
couple years ago titled twelve reasons
why smart people fail so if you haven't
watched this one go watch this and if
you haven't watched the interview with
the CEO and founder of Lululemon go
watch chip Wilson and then outside of
that any question starts comment below
and if you haven't subscribed please do
so take care everybody love you bye-bye
you